[Music]
how do you measure a country's power
by power i mean its ability to impose
its will over other countries
we could measure their gdp their
economic growth or perhaps even the size
of their army
but i've got another idea
the best way of showing your power is
forcing
other countries as large as yours to
make a big
sacrifice this sacrifice might be
something that goes against their will
but
they will do it because you want them to
well this is what trump is trying to do
to the european union
and what is the big sacrifice that he
wants the europeans to make
well that's easy he wants them to cut
their ties with the islamic
republic of iran
[Applause]
but the question is is it really that
big of a sacrifice and most importantly
can he win this bet
well these are the very questions we're
going to answer
in this video
[Music]
iran is that country with all those
independent movies that you say you like
but
you've never never watched but there is
something even more important to iran's
economy and that's
automobiles
[Music]
yes dear viewers iran is actually one of
the biggest car manufacturers
in all of the middle east and i know
what you're probably thinking right now
you're probably thinking
iran really simon developing country
virtually isolated making cars but as
surprised as you might be
they even have their own brand for
example the beautiful vehicle that you
see here is the cadro samant it's a
sudan that's sold in iran azerbaijan
russia and venezuela
okay okay you shouldn't have really
expected anything amazing the engines
are old and the manufacturer does have a
lot to improve
but i mean look what can you expect for
seven
thousand dollars
and seriously we actually think that if
you took this car you improved it with a
bit of modern technology would actually
be quite a good deal
you see we actually think that if you
took this car and proved it with some
modern technology it would still be
cheap and it would probably be like
not a terrible vehicle it would probably
do really well in developing markets
and actually this is why since 2015 when
most of iran's oil sanctions were lifted
many european companies
actually started investing in the
country
raid to enter new joint venture in iran
[Music]
back on the road in iran with deal to
build cars but
there is way way more than cars here you
see the iranian stock market has a
market capitalization
three times bigger than the egyptian one
and they have all kinds of companies
unlike other oil rich countries in the
region iran's economy is surprisingly
diversified
banks mining companies and even telecoms
all exist
and this well has attracted other
european companies too
vodafone marks entry into iran with high
web partnership if this wasn't enough
iran has a well-educated population the
literacy rate is
way higher than that of syria iraq and
many of their neighboring countries
more than 4 million citizens study or
have studied at university and this
means a well-trained workforce that can
work for
really quite low wages add to this the
fact that the country has over 80
million people and
suddenly you've actually got a really
good place for investment nonetheless
this
wave of european money has all of a
sudden
just stopped
[Music]
us will absolutely sanction european
companies that do business with iran but
hold on a minute i mean donald trump
he's the american president he can
make rules for american companies all he
wants but european countries i mean
he's not the president of the world how
can he impose rules over countries that
he doesn't govern
well that is another question we're
going to answer today but before we do
as always let's take a look back at the
history
[Music]
illegal duel in march 2018
zte a chinese phone manufacturer had to
pay a 1
billion fine to the united states
[Music]
why well they imported microchips from
america and sold them to iran the white
house basically saw this
and said aha you're doing business with
the bad guys now you've got to pay this
crazy ass fine or i'm not going to let
you sell your stuff in my country
this is a pretty big deal because if
you're not selling in america
you're not selling in the world's
richest country it's really not an
option so
zte was willing to pay pretty much
anything in order to stay in the market
and well this same thing is happening
with many other companies
[Music]
but as we said european companies
started doing business with iran in
2015.
and we're not talking about buying oil
here but investments
of all kinds this is why as soon as
trump passed
new sanctions the eu confronted him
europe requests exemptions from trump's
iran sanctions for energy
aviation and more basically european
leaders wrote a letter to the white
house asking america to
respect their economic interests as you
know trump is no big fan of the european
union so you can imagine his answer
this is why in 2018 the european union
took
big action it was time for regulation
2271-96
wait you don't know what regulation
2271-96 is all about
oh don't worry no problem that's why i'm
here
[Music]
you see regulation 2271-96 is something
like
a legal shield against trade wars for
example let's say that chevrolet
discovers that
renault has a factory on iranian soil
they could take the french company to an
american court
and make them pay a fine but at that
same moment the european union
would impose an equivalent fine on
chevrolet
but this is still not the end of the
story
[Music]
then suppose renault says well then i'm
going to leave iran anyway there's too
much trouble there
well in that case the european union
could also find the company because
technically they are complying with
washington sanctions
so basically all wrapped up this
basically means that all the companies
doing business with iran
are kind of screwed if they stay
washington screws them if they leave the
european union screws them it's sort of
a really big
lose-lose and it's what's known as a
political duel
so the question is now who is more
powerful who would the european
companies prefer to get screwed by
well now we're going to see
[Music]
reality check i'm sure all of you have
made an international transfer at some
point let's say
you live in canada and you need to be
paid by an australian company when you
send the invoice you don't give your
normal bank details like you'd give to a
company in your country
instead you give this really long number
that also has some letters in it looks
something
like this
[Music]
well these letters are the so-called
swift code
the swift system is what banks use for
international money transfers
it is a network that connects all of the
world's banks
a number of years iran was disconnected
from the swift network
so this means that even if you wanted to
do business with iran
you just couldn't
after all how can you conduct business
with somebody you can't even transfer
money to
of course you could send money in a
briefcase
but that's not very convenient in 2015
when that nuclear deal was signed iran
returned to the swift system
and this was the moment this was the
moment when iran could go back
to the international business scene and
now you might be wondering well who
controls the swift system
well you absolutely guessed it it's of
course a company called
swift the society for worldwide
interbank financial transactions
and guess where they have their
headquarters oh yeah it's in brussels
so yeah i probably know what you're now
thinking you're thinking if all of the
international transactions are managed
in europe then
america doesn't have to do much to avoid
doing business with iran
right well no not right at all very very
wrong you see
swift is actually a cooperative society
this means
all the important decisions made by a
board of managers with 25
representatives
from the most important banks
and inside of this board of managers
there are two americans
one is from citibank and another is from
jpmorgan chase
these two representatives will have to
pay crazy fines if they can't convince
their colleagues to disconnect iran from
the swift system
if this happened iran would be isolated
from the international market
if you can't make transactions you can't
do business it's really just that simple
this is such an important matter that
the european union is already trying to
come up with an alternative system
for international transactions something
like a modern day barter system
they call it spv or special purpose
vehicle the idea is that instead of
exchanging goods for money
europe wants to pay with credits for
other goods
for example let's say that repsol a
spanish company wants to buy oil from
iran well
instead of paying with cash they could
pay with an equivalent some
in machinery
so now you might be only well we got rid
of a bar system really long time ago
could something like this
really work today well the answer is
only time is going to be able to tell
but let's
assume that it actually does let's say
the companies start using this spv
system to trade with iran
so let's go back to our reptile example
this dinosaur juice they just bought has
to arrive somehow
right somehow somebody has to put it on
a tanker and
take it into barcelona's harbor well
most of the oil tankers
on the planet they're managed by a
danish company called maersk
and denmark well that's in europe but
hold on a second
no harbor is going to accept an oil ship
if it's not insured
it turns out most of the insurance
companies that work with oil tankers are
american
or have a lot of interest in america
which
explains news like this
[Music]
shipping giant maersk to abandon iran as
threat of sanctions grows
other countries like china they've
already found alternatives they have
enough at stake to convince them to do
everything they can to keep oil supplies
coming in from iran
it's their sixth biggest provider seven
percent of their dino juice comes from
tehran
but europe europe's a different animal
in that case iran isn't important enough
to
risk so much on this in other words if
europe wanted to keep buying crude oil
from iran they would have to find
one new transport companies two new
insurance companies
and three they would have to use
bartering
okay and look anything is really
possible but so far it does seem that
america and donald trump is
gonna win this match against the
european union and all of this
has got a whole bunch of consequences in
a previous video we talked about what's
happening with the international all
markets
in the following weeks we want to talk
about what's going to happen to the
iranian regime
meanwhile the big question is can these
sanctions end
the iranian regime how much can oil
prices go up you can write
me your theories in the following days
let's have a look and see if they match
with ours
in the meantime do visit reconsider
media that's the podcast that provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine
also do not forget brand new videos
every week so
hit that subscribe button and click the
bell icon so you don't miss out on any
updates and if you like this video
do give it a thumbs up and as always
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you